hello everyone thanks for joining our
call our talk today I'm Mike this is my
colleague Maria and we are talking about
Auto grading today before we get into
the NLP and all the difficult stuff let
me ask a simple question who of you
likes grading who enjoys it okay
but it's I've only seen two hands and
the reason is it's typically very
tedious and boring and it doesn't get
more fun if you have to create hundreds
of tests from a like school perspective
it's very expensive labor intense and
students also don't like it because it
takes a lot of time to get them feedback
and it's also prone to human error you
have to go back and kind of get the
corrections on your gratings so what we
need is Auto grading and how do we do
that there are many tools out there most
of them use a black and white black or
white approach so you have a model
solution you compare a student answer to
the model solution and if it's right
gets full points otherwise nothing and
this would just not work for higher
education so what we have done is like
thinking carefully about how can we kind
of state a typical question in an
assessment so that it can be graded by a
computer and the answer the answer is
actually pretty simple so you can
transform any problem or task into the
following kind of formulation find an
instance of entity type such that
conditions see eye hole
and with this approach we can great
everything like multiple choice
questions free response questions and
also all kinds of interactive other
question types to get a better idea of
what I mean by this entity type and
conditions I sharing an example here we
created a tool called Treo that's based
on Mathematica and it allows you to set
up questions and here we have an example
I hope yeah I hope you can read it an
example question name a city within 300
miles to London which is outside the UK
and to grade such a question
automatically it would not really work
if you just oh if you try to set up all
the possible solutions to that questions
in both from alpha there are more than
150 thousand known cities and yeah so it
would just not be fun to do that instead
what we do is we specify what is this
thing what we're looking for the entity
type and in this case it's a city and
then we set up conditions instead of
stating like the model solution so this
is what is done here in this like two
lines of code so the given answer is
taken and yes
is it better now so again here here was
just a good question name a city with
internet miles to London which is
outside the UK and now we're
transforming this using two conditions
condition number one is that the Geo
distance from London to the given answer
of the student is less than 300 miles
and the second condition would be in
this case the it's not within the United
Kingdom
so with that way we can also distinguish
like several like partially correct
states of a question so let's try this
okay so what you see here is on the web
using the DeVoe from private cloud and
now I can go ahead and type something
like Paris and to make it a little more
fun to also say Tokyo and let's do it
another time
using Glasgow
all right and now we already have the
grading results so in this case Paris is
correct and if we look at the details
here we have the first condition
evaluates to true the second to true and
that's why we end up with three out of
three points if we use Tokyo then the
first condition would not be satisfied
so we have it partially correct and so
on that's the idea of condition based
grading it works for everything I use it
for grading like coding challenges and
we use it for statistics and and all
kinds of different fields it can be used
on images and Excel sheets or whatever
you name it now this is a really
powerful approach and many educators
would like to use it by the way if you
are interested in using this please
visit AC or come talk to us we have a
workshop tomorrow where we go into a
little more details on like how to use
it for teaching today we focus just on
grading but if you're interested please
feel free to reach out so I've talked to
many educators in the last couple of
years and so what they said is this is
this is cool but they are a little
frightened of like writing those
conditions like writing these lines of
code for someone who is new to the
Wolfram language this can be like a
little tough so our idea was maybe we
can derive those conditions using NLP
using the same kind of ideas that it's
been used in in Wolfram Alpha that's
that's one main motivation
for this project so we want to remove
the coding barrier for educators and the
second one is also we want to challenge
the purely statistical approaches of
Auto grading and trying to combine it
with something like rule-based trying to
understand grammars in plain English so
here is an example and we want to with
this in trying to to achieve this we
want to start with simple problems with
so-called math word problems so they are
used in elementary school and he is a
typical one John found seventy seashells
on the beach she gave him some of our
seashells
she has 727 now how many seashells did
she gives to Sam and so this is it like
a typical math word problem and we want
to grade this automatically what we want
on top and which is our variable is
already kind of implemented in creo and
our grading approach is that we can
parameterize it so we can use different
names numbers for each student and what
we don't want obviously is to calculate
this manually and to write the code so
what do we need to do for any plain
English question or task statement we
need to pass it we need to derive those
conditions and the model solution and
then based on that we can do the actual
evaluation of student answers so this is
already implemented in the platform the
the grading approach today we focus on
the first two points
and Maria will now explain you how we do
that thank you Mike can you hear me
so this is our approach first we have
the input sentence which is exactly the
one Mike showed before and then we are
allocating the sentence to either
addition subtraction division or
multiplication and after we have select
the operator type we are automatically
creating a grammar rule and then we
apply the input sentence to the grammar
rule and with the direct solution we
compare it to a correct one from the
data set and then we get the results
either it's true/false or failed and
based on false and faith we are
improving our model so let me introduce
you to our data set
it's called aggregate and consists of
1492 and medic word problems here you
see an overview of the operator types
and for this project we are focusing
only on the single operator problems and
we did some text structure analysis
based on comparison by distance matrices
I have a link in appendix if you want to
read more into that and we found out
that there are 713 different text
structure but looking at the same one
they were grammatically quite different
and used also different operator types
to derive the correct solution and then
we did some part of speech tagging
sequences with we analyzed the text
structure based on the part of speech
sequences and there we found out that
there are 1300 18 different text
structures so the data set is pretty
heterogeneous and the questions are not
that similar to each other
so this is a specific example of her
data set it's exactly the same sentence
as before and we have the equation the
correct solution and then we took out
the question part itself this one we are
using for the location and also we here
we have all the sentences with numerical
information this one we are using for
the grammar rules so now we have the
input sentence and we want to allocate
it to its operator class there we try
two methods one is using keywords so we
checked whether the question comes
contained any of this keyword and there
we got a rough overview of the results
it can be improved but for now we are
working with this 286 correctly
allocated additions for the later steps
and we also use the classify function
and when we use the for operator types
we got an accuracy of 46 and when we
split it to either addition or
subtraction versus multiplication and
division we got an accuracy of 89 now we
are going to create the actual grammar
rules I'm not sure if you're familiar
with grammar rules but this is a simple
one so you have the fixed order then the
grammar tokens your given name and city
and then the actual rule so X errors Y
and we have to cloud deploy the grammar
rule and we if we insert the sentence
which matches the structure it will give
out this expression so here Michael goes
to Zurich and how we are using this is
with the following steps so first we do
part of speech tagging and then we
creating these grammar tokens and then
we create a whole left-hand part of the
grammar rule and based on these
we will create the right-hand side of
the grammar rule and combining these
together we are creating the full
grammar rule and deploy to the cloud so
here we can see a specific example
Thomas nine yellow balloons sarah has
eight yellow balloons now we are doing
the part of speech tagging I'm not sure
if you can read it but it says Tom
proper noun has were nine is numeral and
so on and then we are doing the
left-hand side of the grammar rule so we
are creating grammar tokens and in front
of the semantic numbers we got the
variables a and B and based on that we
are creating the right-hand side of the
grammar rules because we know that these
are addition questions it's just a plus
B and after that we create the whole
grammar rule and deploy that to the
cloud and if we use the same input
sentence it should give us the correct
solution 70 and that's also the solution
that the data set gives us and now
thinking back to the teacher she wants
to change the name the numbers and the
objects right so we can use the same
grammar and just use the same sentence
structure and it will compute us the
correct solution so now we applied it to
this 286 correctly located additions and
from these 283 cloud objects were
created and 130 were true forty-one were
false 112 failed and we want to learn
from these false and failed ones so why
are they false and why did they fail
so one of the reason is that in the
first steps where we do the part of
speech tagging you see that the number 4
is not recognized as numeral but as
adjectives so if we do a grammar based
on that it will give us a wrong solution
so here's it's 9 but because it didn't
recognize the 4 now we are changing this
4.0 to 4 and then actually it will be
recognized as numeral and we are cried
creating a new grammar and for the
application it doesn't matter if it's
4.0 or 4 and we get the correct solution
so we changed this in the data set and
you see we got a little bit more truth
little bit less false and some of the
failed yeah
took your field another reason is why
the grammar is false is because the
sentence is more complex and it contains
irrelevant numbers like this one we are
currently not able to compute it but if
we extend our grammar rules and make
more refined rules I think we'll be able
to do that and you might ask why grammar
apply failed and then and one of the
reasons is because we have some
technical issues I post a question on
Stack Exchange if someone can help
please and another one is currently
after we have limited all proper nouns
to be given names which is of course not
true it's also see it isn't things so to
recap we want to allocate the sentence
to its operator type we want to
automatically create a grammar rule and
based on the false and faith analysis we
want to improve our model so
independence you have the source
so we are state that's the work in
progress so if you have any ideas or
socialism please let me know big time so
we're happy to take questions